if I give you absolute power would you
be able to uh what would you change what
does absolute power mean like you said
to me listen you're going to be the
dictator of planet Earth and anything
that you want is at your means including
violence sex no I would not
because even in my personal life now
there are things that I could do right
that I have power I guess
that I don't participate in right so why
would I do it if I had ultimate power
maybe because there's always there's
still a moral and ethics that I have
right that I don't feel comfortable with
right so you wouldn't even enjoy it
no I mean I think that um there would be
no if I had ultimate dictatorship on
planet Earth there would be no violence
I mean I would not cause any wars right
but if there's an uprising yeah I'd have
to quell it that's how it starts Bobby
you quell it don't surprise
right but so first you're gonna censor
everybody who wants to even suggest the
idea of Uprising and then and then one
person gets out of line they run a red
light okay that's that's but but here
we're getting green Traffic
yeah
I get raidful so if you could murder
that person no no no no no
body has to know no I would give them
cancer
but I would have not so much
[Laughter]
okay no but no but here no this is an
interesting thing because I want I want
I want to elaborate all right so
the thing if I was the dictator of the
planet earth right
um there would be a reason why people
would uprise right so give me a reason
because I would give them food shelter
right and all the things I feel like
that that people would desire right
but but you're right but you're right
because they're you're right I I think
this is what you're talking about yeah
so here's the deal so there are certain
things that I do believe in right like
for instance it's a very controversial
thing right in terms of a woman's right
right in terms of abortion right I feel
like as a male I it's not my body so I
don't really even have an opinion and I
shouldn't even have a voice on it
because you know I mean a woman like
it's like if they created laws if white
people men create laws for Koreans in
America like you don't have the right to
right so it's like so if I was if I was
a dictator right I would just be like
yeah women have all the rights in the
world right and they you know and I
think
abortion should be legal throughout the
planet earth right but there will be
people out there that will believe that
no you know what I mean
we you know we're pro-life so you would
put them in jail so that's right so I
think as a dictator you there was no way
to be able to please everyone so there
will be an uprising yeah so yeah [ __ ] it
I don't want to do it okay would you do
it
uh not no there's several loaded
questions would I enjoy it no would I uh
do it no because I don't trust my own
mind under power like I'm well aware
that uh in situations where I have
control it's it's as much of Freedom as
it is a burden like it can change you
I'm very nervous about that interesting
like how much uh
uh how much the ego starts to flare up
how much just like the less uh Pleasant
things about your nature come up you
know I have a temper too like I have all
that kind of stuff and uh you have I'm
sure you have a bit of a template yeah I
have a temper yeah and so whenever
nobody is able to as clearly call you
out on your [ __ ] that's that could
be a problem
do you have this when you you when you
rage out you have a temper is there like
like either a day later or a couple
hours later is there shame and regret
that comes along with that or no yeah no
no no of course yeah during it yeah
during it too yeah shame and regret yeah
yeah and then but I try to make sure
it's like love and respect are felt
always underneath the whole thing
um but still it's like human emotion you
can't control it and if you give an
absolute power you start to lose your
sense of the world you start to be
unable to see what is right and wrong
you think everybody everything is right
you start to be
um have a distorted view of who is doing
the wrong things in the world and then
also distrust
well that has to do more with how
absolute power is usually attained
because when you're in the seat of power
everybody first on the outside but then
in your inner circle you start to
distrust them you start to believe that
they're going to they want your power so
the people you love the people that were
source of so much Beauty for you
previously uh like even like your
girlfriend wife your closest lifelong
friends you start to suspect them I
don't want to live like that yeah yeah
and you're often right to suspect them
so because you think they change a
little bit too they change too yeah they
start to get a little bit taste of that
power yeah it's the interesting thing is
a bunch of people in the in Hitler's
Inner Circle at the very end betrayed
him to in in search of their own power
wow fascinating it's fascinating this
power thing